pleased to have here uh on the show uh
his new book talking to goats is
available where all
books are sold go get it today uh the
great jim gray back here on the show how
are you jim
i'm doing great rich how are you i am
fine i am sorry i'm a couple minutes
late to get to you and uh
no it's all good um look uh there's
nothing more personal than writing a
book
nothing more personal than writing a
book and uh this is now on the shelf
forever more what made you want to do
this jim
i just felt it was time with everything
that had gone on and um
it's been 43 years in broadcasting and
thousands upon thousands of interviews
and events and
just kind of all added up and stedman
graham
always tells me two things he's written
12 books he says jim gray they're paying
you to talk just keep talking
get all this down on paper so i finally
took his advice
okay and how long did it take you uh i
mean did you get any do you have any
help here or
did okay greg bishop of sports
illustrated did a
tremendous job he wrote the book with me
it took us just under three years
and wow he went through all these
interviews and transcripts and
dug up all these stories with me and
really did a great job a really diligent
terrific writer
anything um that you saw as a thread
through line to the goats that you're
referring to uh you put
many of them on the front cover of your
book you had uh uh tom brady's the
writing the forward is there a through
line that you that you found
with all of these people that you have
spoken to so successful that they were
i i think they all have you know those
basic components of hard work dedication
and and their myopic in their pursuit of
that excellence
right but they all seem to go about it
in much different ways
and how so well i mean you know some of
them are tormented by that ability to
touch perfection but not grasp it like
michael phelps who spent his entire life
you know as an adult staring at a black
line to try and get a fingernail
to the end of the board first and
you know that that just think about just
think about that statement and what that
might do to you
um floyd mayweather defined himself much
differently
with a 50-0 record that oh after his
name meant everything to him and also
that oh after his bank account meant
everything to him that's right
uh whereas don shula you know the
perfect season uh
end up defining him not only the 347
wins which is the most all-time
but what what he want what he wanted for
his team
and to have 1972
be remembered forever so uh everybody
goes about it differently tom brady
obviously
um he wants to touch it again and again
and again and again and he can't hold on
to it
but he's had the perfect quarter he's
had the perfect comeback he's had
you know all of those things but what
drives him is to do it you know for the
seventh time now
um and kobe bryant didn't matter to him
kobe bryant was going to win
no matter what and the commitment to win
it didn't matter who you were if you
were a teammate
or an opponent you were in the way he
knocked you over so
um they all go about it differently but
they all are trying to reach the same
place
jim gray here on the rich eisen show
12-time emmy award winner and now
author talking to goats where all books
are sold is it
safe to assume that uh you've
interviewed brady more than anybody else
because of your week
to week conversation that you've had
with him for all these years i i would
say that's various
so then what what what do you think he's
thinking right now jim today
yes sir today after last night he's
thinking how did i lose that game and
why did i throw those passes and how am
i going to get better next week and it's
a short week and it's a short
you know memory and the
losses do linger much much longer
than the victories and so um
i'm sure he's beating himself up today
and it's it's not a good day for him
or his teammates and you know he wants
to uh
doesn't want that to happen and he
didn't you know
it's not what we're used to seeing in in
in the end of games but
you know it's inevitable too um look
unlike boxing where you're defined by
one loss now
how many games did the did the chief
lose last year you can still be a
champion that's the point uh
it it one game can go quickly in the nfl
it wasn't three or four weeks ago
everybody thought they were the best
team in the nfl and then they played the
saints and
had a bad performance and they played
last night and wasn't a bad performance
it just wasn't a victory
no i know i mean all those uh america's
game documentaries that nfl films puts
together so expertly uh all those six of
them that brady's patriots were able to
uh place in front of the uh mavens that
nfl films to put together
uh you know all of them had some sort of
adversity that they had to face
at some point and it appears that we are
seeing that right now
for tom why do you think he's still
doing it
jim because he still can and he still
you know
again what have we seen these five
interceptions in those two games before
that it was
20 touchdowns and what five or six
interceptions on the year
and a couple of them three or four of
them came very early in the season so he
went 200 passes because he can still do
it his arm strength is there
his mind is still there his abilities
are all still there
and it's not like you know frank laden
said it many many years ago he was a
great coach for the utah jazz and he had
a bad season he says
you folks think i went dumb overnight
okay
so he was the coach of the year or
whatever he was and terrific and so
he can still do it and you know i
that's why he does it because he loves
football and he loves his family
and that's what his life is so
he always says why do everybody want me
to retire well they want me to retire
because he used to say they hate me in
31 cities now they hate him in 30 cities
boston still i believe loves him and uh
and pampa loves him so
everybody else wants a chance to win so
it's not over yet
he always says football starts at
thanksgiving
so that's this week so it's not a very
good prelude uh for the bucks
uh going into thanksgiving but let's see
where they are next week and it won't
get any easier with kansas city few more
minutes left with jim gray talking to
goats uh
any of your interviews throughout your
career that
you wanted to make sure uh is
spotlighted in this book because
it's a story you wanted to get out a
back story you wanted to get out
uh certainly when there's so many
narratives involving many of your
interviews
throughout the years jim well i think
you know
the decision now 10 years in the
rearview mirror there's a chapter on
that and
we discuss everything that went on with
that show and
what it looks like now today pete rose
that was 21 years ago that caused a lot
of controversy and agita and tumult and
we go through that and by the way after
21 years
about two and a half weeks ago for a
special on fox
that just aired i went back and sat down
with pete rose and we spoke for an hour
so it was a really interesting
conversation
and really went well and so i was glad
that pete did that so those are two
obviously a chapter on tiger woods one
of the first interviews that he ever did
where he predicted his greatness so when
he was nine years old
said when i grow up i want to win all
the majors and feed all the pros
became a very famous nike commercial yes
um so there's there's just a lot in here
that
you know not necessarily wanting to set
any records straight but just my version
of events of what's gone on and what
i've learned and
what the public can learn through all of
these guys you know
great athletic achievements and and
their trials and tribulations what was
more interesting the conversation you
had on
camera with pete or the off camera one
to set up the on camera jim well
here's what happened rich about a year
ago
the cancer society asked me to come and
introduce mike tyson who was being
honored
and that same night pete rose was being
honored so pete walked over to the table
and i said to my wife fran uh-oh how's
this gonna go
so i stood up and he extended his hand
and he said jim you do a great job
you're really terrific at what you do
and i looked at him and he said it again
i said you really don't mean that pete
do you said no i really do what happened
between us
is 20 years ago and a lot has changed a
lot has gone on
so mike tyson stood up because we didn't
know what was going to happen and
pete says to mike who do you think would
have won that fight between gemini and
he said there's no question jim would
have killed you
[Music]
so that broke all the ice okay so right
you know we had a nice conversation
and i just figured you know it's been 21
years the book is coming out
fox is nice enough to give me a special
on the book right and
i called her pete and he said yes right
away drove over to las vegas
and we sat down at the bellagio hotel
and
we talked about that night he said you
were just doing your job i recognized
the timing
and recognized that you know the tone of
that from
people having a melancholy feeling of
seeing ted williams and sandy colfax and
all their heroes
right that you know perhaps what i
should have done uh
could have taken place at any other time
but on that night it was actually his
hall of fame celebration that the fans
were giving him so
you know uh we we just went through it
and uh
you know reminisced and spoke about
everything that transpired after that
but uh mike tyson was ready to step in
and be yours yeah he was ready to step
in on your behalf yeah because you know
mike
mike really uh just kind of guards me
everywhere i go
well then put him on the phone jim
that's not that's not hard
you you need mike on your show no no no
no i thought he's right next to you is
what i'm saying
right now no no he's with kiki training
for his fight this weekend that's right
oh my god isn't that amazing oh my god
quite a guy
mike tyson there's a lot more to him
that's the name of the chapter in the
book uh
much more than the bite much more than
the bite uh jim i appreciate the time
congrats on the book congrats on getting
it all out there hope you sell a lot of
them and everybody should uh
go get uh talking to goats where all
books are sold appreciate the time jim
rich appreciate you thanks for having me
happy thanksgiving to you and susie and
the family and
you're the best thank you right back at
you thank you jim that's uh jim gray
right here
forward by tom brady hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here